all right hello my name is Sebastian Mei
love and today it is a historic day
because I'm gonna test out tactics
frenzy it's not finished
completely yet but I'm so eager to test
out this new feature of play Magnus and
today I want to actually show you well
how high rating can we get in five
minutes so let's go train at your own
speed
so first tactic well we'll have to get
rid of these pieces I think I'm gonna
change the color and I'm also going to
change the p-set alright there we go
much better alright this is an
interesting one I'm already stuck on the
first puzzle
okay 97 Queen 68 followed by Ruth d8
checkmate that's the first one puzzle
sold
alright here's the next one hmm
oh yeah easy rook h1 followed by Knight
xf 2 with a nice fork there we go
1600 can we reach 1800 I think we can as
Barack Obama would say yes yes we can
okay this seems harder this seems a lot
harder actually I have no IDE
followed by by 97 and then and then my
friend 96 oh it's a draw okay it's a
draw that's disappointing but anyway we
solve it alright so I'm supposed to win
right f4 is like a tip it's not a way to
win it so if I play a success King b6
that's a huge issue so I think maybe not
f5
probably not a good idea grab the pawn
sorry that was not the best move
oops what is that I have no idea what
the solution is but okay um maybe I have
to go further down here solution I would
like to see that King h1 wha what king
h1 king
wise King takes d4 the right move here
why not like Bishop d2 or something that
doesn't work you have not b3 all right
fair enough
next one 1600
that is not impressive did I have to do
better than that you've got to do better
than that all right
if I can do bishop labor should be one
here and it would be nice what that is
sorry that was not the best move gotta
be kidding me what do you do after that
threatening Queen takes up five and if
you take on d6 you're losing maybe you
have your okay to there well let's see
okay I can just take immediately wow I
missed made into wow that's kind of
disappointing for a man of my caliber
right I think I'm just gonna take on g6
but then yes c4 okay problems
trouble in the bathroom I suppose okay I
just not initially I can just play queen
h5 so he does that but then I can just
play crew t6 should I fire we'll take it
thank you very much and I'll take that
Wow okay wonderful and here we have yet
another puzzle I'm having a hard time on
these good good job by these guys
challenging challenging puzzles he's
threatening to play well Queen takes G
to checkmate I have to do something
about that to do something about that
really quick
maybe there should be four and if it
takes it I'm going to play Queen c3 then
he has Queens to six and what do i do
then that is
she may be like rook takes piece up now
it doesn't work he just takes me the
King Jesus I can't believe that this is
a 1600 exercise I had literally no idea
what to do here yeah well I have to
prevent the matin or something one way
to do that so I'm gonna try sorry that
was not the right move
Oh what I didn't understand that one
wonderful okay uh I'm having a hard time
all this checkmate
so 1400 what is my rating 1600 I think
so okay he's threatening mate that means
I have to check him so I'll check here
and it's checkmate okay that was way
easier than the previews one so so we
have 1600 and something we're gonna
capture that bishop followed by
checkmate I don't have a timer though
I'm not sure how long I've been doing
these exercises now but I'm probably
running out of time soon
oh I've seen this one oh I know this one
I have to do this one so if I play Queen
h6 it takes enough six
oops which is why you play d5 first I
think and then you play Queen f6 cuz see
well you can't defend the mate
well I'll do one more and then we're
we're done okay why to draw well that's
easy take and then perpetual very nice
black to draw back and forth now it's
also nice and I believe our time is up
this is how far I was able to get in
five minutes close to 1800 terrible
performance by me I have to say I can
see the solution for this one rotates
and King Queen King c6 that's a nice one
but I do hope that you enjoyed this
video so I'm gonna end it right now stop
the puzzle and well thank you so much
for for watching I am your host
Sebastian mihailov and I will see you
next